so this is joint work with felipe cooker
i'm going to tell you about
so my first
transparency is just motivation actually
there's no need for motivation in this
workshop it's dedicated
to uh studying the
uh how to solve polynomial equations
that's of course a very fundamental
problem and we know
it's an np-hard problem if you look at
it over the 5v2 elements it's np
complete it's also mp complete if you
look at it over the complex numbers in
the bloom shop smail model
and there has been a lot of work in
symbolic computation
it has been studied in detail not only
practically but also in terms of
complexity
but the problem is with all these
methods um
the running time somehow is exponential
so if you have
like if like d is a an upper bound on
degree of the polynomials and n is the
number of variables you always have
this this d to the n
in the upper bound so if you for
instance if you have a system of
quadratic equations it will be something
like 2 to the m
okay in all these symbolic methods and
the question is whether one can do
better
nowadays there's this field of numerical
algebraic geometry that is growing we
have heard several talks about that in
this workshop
and
these are these methods can go much
further they can solve much bigger
problems
um they perform better in practice and
the goal of my talk is i try to
understand from the complexity point of
view why this is the case so i want to
that's the goal
and somehow hoping to in the end
it will require a lot of research but at
the moment there is a huge gap between
what we can see in practice and what we
can actually prove we try to narrow this
gap
so it's always good to have some
light tower or leading problem
and there was a problem that was posed
by steve smail
some time ago and it reads as follows
we have given is a system of
complex polynomial equations
and polynomials in n unknowns and we
want to solve it we want to compute the
solution how difficult is that and he
asked can it be
can such a solution be found
approximately on the average in
polynomial time by uniform algorithm so
these expressions these words in blue at
the moment are not precisely defined
that we're going to define them later on
but this is the problem yeah it's a we
ask for polynomial time you don't want
to go away from
these two to the end
okay and this problem has its origin in
a series of papers by uh
written by mike schubert and steve smale
at the beginning of the 90s
they all have in the title complexity of
bezu theorem and then it goes one two
three four five and then it stopped
and
okay and then partly in that paper
actually in bezu five this problem was
partly solved but not completely
so uh okay and then later on uh viltron
and pardo
took up the story again
and
they had a very nice idea android that
i'm going to explain and they came up
with an answer with a positive answer to
this problem by steve smell
positive when you allow randomized
algorithms
okay
so
and okay let me
briefly explain
the work that i've done with felipe what
are our contributions
so in a sense there are
okay different results and the
enlarged kind of the toolbox
so one result was that we found a
deterministic
algorithm for small 17's problem and
it's almost polynomial time
so if n is the input size and the
polynomial is given in dense
representation
capital n is the input size meaning that
number of coefficients so it's not bit
size
then the expected runny time well
okay
expect it the algorithm is deterministic
but the average over the input space in
the certain
mean
i will explain you expected what it
means
then the average
running time will be n to the o log log
n so it's almost polynomial and actually
what we prove a little bit more if you
restrict ourselves to systems of bounded
degree think of a system of quadratic
polynomials then it's actually
the expected running time is polynomial
so in this case it will be n squared
okay so this was one result
the other result
okay
so
d is so you have a degree fixed right
then it's
polynomial there will be more details
but you see okay
there will be more details there will be
this is just overview there will be more
details there will be more precise
statements so if you'll be patient
uh
good
this is just the overview
so let me briefly talk about this idea
of smooth analysis
so we want to analyze algorithms
but what traditionally has been done in
computer science is worst case
worst case
and sometimes average case yeah
especially when you have algorithms like
the simplex algorithm where we know it
works well in practice but there are bad
inputs they are very rare and hard to
construct but still they exist so we
want to have a theoretical justification
why the algorithm is good so what people
did they did an average analysis but the
problem is the average analysis is not
so convincing because the input is never
follows these distributions so there was
this great idea by dan spielman and sean
wang thing
so
more than 10 years ago
they they smoothed analysis
they said
well pictorially if you want
it's very easy to explain
so this is your
you have your input here
and then you assume that it has some
noise
okay
maybe maybe you model this by a gaussian
that is has a mean f bar
and some variance sigma square
okay so yeah and then
what you do if you have a let's say t in
the is the running time of the algorithm
that you are studying
so this is a function of your input f
and then what you do
you take the expectation
over this noise so
there is a local expectation and then
you want to bound this
and you want to bound it over all
centers f bar you don't know you don't
care where this is you want to
bound this by a small quantity and if
you can do that
then you're happy of course this
quantity will involve
this variance sigma and if sigma is very
small then this will grow
okay so this is the idea of smooth
analysis
and what we managed to do we managed to
perform a smooth analysis
of
this algorithm this randomized algorithm
that was proposed by peltron pardo so we
get smooth expected running time so this
is the overview but i
right so okay this of course was a bit
weak
now um in order to state this
precisely i have to introduce notation
okay so this is an important slide and i
will come back to it uh it
contains a lot of the definitions
so let's go through that
so i fix some degree vector d d1 up to
dn
and this will define my input space
denote it
this calligraphic d hd
so
what are the elements of hd these are
n-tuples of polynomials of homogeneous
polynomials
f is f1 up to fn and fi is a homogeneous
polynomial of degree d i in m plus one
variables
okay so i
the input size is just the
dimension the complex dimension of this
vector space so yeah now
what is the output space
it's complex complex projective space so
i would should say
uh well we want to in the end we will
want to analyze an algorithm so we want
to make use of the geometry of the
problem so everybody in algebraic
geometry agrees that complex projective
space is the nicest space you can think
of that's why we look at projective
situation of affine situation so
everything is homogenized the output
space is complex projective space so we
look for a zero in this space
of the given f
okay
then we need to measure distances so we
have a
a metric on the complex protective space
which is
think of it as terms of an angle it
comes from the so-called fubini studio
metric that's not so important think of
projective space as something like a
sphere
and we are measuring angular distance i
denote it by d
also i have to measure distances between
inputs because i want to talk about
condition i want to say what happens if
i have an input f and i perturb it a
little bit
and now it's important to
choose the right distant measure so what
i do and what i do what the
human smell have done all the time they
choose an inner product
on
the input space hd that is invariant
under the action of the unitary group so
we have a symmetry here we can have an
orthogonal transformation
on my on the input space in the natural
way and of course this induces uh
orthogonal unit area i wanted to say of
course this defines a transformation an
operation of the unitary group on this
space
yeah
okay
and there is not much choice here
so we choose one of these hermitian
inner products let's call it the while
in the product and once i have this
i can talk about the norm of an input
and about angles okay about angles
so
i have this notion of angular distance
okay
good
and then
last notion on this slide this is a what
we call the solution variety so it's an
incidence variety it consists of all
pairs f and zeta
f is an input it's an element of hd zeta
is a zero
okay so this is a subset
of this algebraic variety you want to
prove it's a manifold
so i think it's important here to
understand that
okay
it's a design question what should the
input space
be
now if you see if i have this f here and
then multiply f by hundred
what will change nothing i mean the
zeros will be the same
so one could say
maybe the input space would rather be
the projective space
that belongs to hd okay i could do that
i could also scale this f1 up to fn
individually this is another possibility
that don't do it here so okay
but for some reason and for our
techniques it will be very important
that you also have this notion of norm
even though it doesn't have a meaning
for the problem it doesn't have a
meaning for the problem directly but it
will be very important
in the analysis
okay
so is why is this solution variety
smooth
it's a fiber bundle in this direction
thank you frank i couldn't have answered
it
thank
you okay condition number one
okay
yeah it's a vector bar it depends on the
vector bond on the fiber bond
so just
this
important let's say let's say we just
have one quadratic equation right
and
and then we have this
hypersurface in pn when the quadratic
equation drops rank
the quadratic becomes singular
the projection onto pn becomes singular
but you're saying the fiber overlapping
you're looking at it's an incidence
variety varieties are usually smooth
fiber bundles so i see this is an
incidence or idea for
each corner it's a linear space non-zero
linear space oh sure yeah okay i got it
okay
it's a great trick everybody should know
that yeah yeah okay i agree
it's a great trick
so what is condition number
so um
now
very simple our input is f and we have a
perturbation of f okay maybe the data is
inaccurate and i don't know what then it
will have some impact the solution zeta
will change somehow we have to quantify
this
so this can be quantified by the
condition number
so uh what happens here so you see here
i wrote it here just uh
as a definition
but let me explain a little bit that's
very important
so what is this com condition number
this is just a formula um
actually okay maybe i should explain it
so i just
okay i want to convince you that what we
do here is very very natural it's very
very natural
so this f seat is in the solution
variety and then i project it
down to f
okay
now uh
projection let's call it taiwan
so what we do we take the derivative so
we have a tangent space here
this goes to the tangent space here
which i can identify with this okay this
is the derivative
i don't write the argument
okay
if
the zeta happens to be a
a simple zero of f then this is a
subjective map
actually it's an isomorphism
it's a nice form with an isomorphism so
i can locally invert it
so i can so this is this this will be
nice so morphism so i can locally invert
this map
so then i get
this map g i call the solution map
so this map just takes the input f and
gives me zero zeta
you see if you have one f
in general that you will have many many
zeros i mean by the zoo theorem you have
the zoom number which is the product of
the degrees many zeros so you pick one
of those but locally
you have this move dependence
okay so how do we define the condition
number
so we
right so we have this g
this is g what we take
the derivative of g
okay
so this grows from the tangent space of
the input space to the
okay it would go to the tangent space of
the projective space
it's a linear map it's a linear map
and then so okay now on these vector
spaces here we have
we have norms
because here on this hd we have chosen
the hermitian in the product so we have
a norm here on this space we also have a
norm so we can talk about
operator norm of this derivative
we take the operator norm of this linear
map and this is this is the condition
this is the condition number
essentially
okay here one has to in order to make
turn it into scale invariant we we put
this norm of f here but uh that's what
it is
so you see what i want to stress here
that this is like a very general
framework we are working in and i
explained this framework to you in the
setting of polynomial system solving but
it's very very general okay mike tube
will this afternoon talk about the
problem to compute an eigenvalue
eigenvector
the same methodology applies
okay
okay maybe what what is
right
so this is the conditional so if you
work this out this is actually
exercise in calculus
so if you know calculus
you can do this exercise and then you
will get
essentially this formula so what you get
here
the derivative of f
think of f as a map from
z n plus 1 to c n you take the
derivative this is a matrix it's an n
times n plus 1 matrix then here i
decorate it and multiply it with this
diagonal matrix this is just for
technical reasons actually you go you
don't get this when you do this
calculation it's not important for this
the purpose of the survey talk
essentially m is this matrix the
derivative of f at zeta
you take the more pendulus inverse the
norm
then you multiply with this and why do i
have to do this
i want to have a notion
that is
invariant on the scaling yeah if i
multiply f by hundred the condition
number shouldn't change so what happens
if i multiply f by hundred
this matrix is multiplied by a hundred
because i have the inverse here it's
multiplied by one over n hundred but
because i have this it compensates so
it's a scale invariant
excuse me but this works well even if df
is a singular
matrix
all of the theory only i'm only i'm
focusing on simple zeros
if there are multiple zeros i can't say
anything
yeah because but i will do this local
averaging i don't see the singular
solutions so
okay think of the
everything is smooth
so okay
so to summarize this condition number is
well defined actually on the projective
space of hd times pn
okay
i have to go on
so
then what we do here
i have to explain the algorithm
uh we do a newton iteration as everybody
does
so everybody knows what is newton
iteration here the only the only twist
to this problem is that we have this
projective space
so you have there are some choices to do
and i don't want to go into the detail
believe me it's quite straightforward to
come up
with the newton operator n sub f will be
the rational math from p n to p n that i
can iterate and if i have a starting
point x0 then i do this iteration and
hopefully
it will converge quickly
to a zero okay and this hopefully has
turned into a theorem
by steve smith sometimes
called this the gamma theory gregorio
has talked about it in one of our
seminars and even proved it for the
f1 case so what is this
theorem saying
well
well we all know that if the starting
point of the newton iteration is
sufficiently close to a simple zero then
we have quadratic convergence that's
what we learn in our classes in
numerical analysis but what does it mean
to be sufficiently close and here is a
quantitative statement saying that if
your
zeta is the zero x0 is the approximation
if this distance in projective space is
less than some constants forget about
the d essentially less than one over the
condition
of the pair f theta
and then if you start your newton
iteration at the x zero you
have immediate conversions with
probative speed
okay
let's a theorem so
okay what else do we need
ah okay what we say here we say x0 is
approximate zero of f if this inequality
is satisfied so this
explains one of the notions that
appeared in the statement of small 17.
so this has a precise meaning
so now
then another idea
that we are all familiar with i mean
homotopic continuation charles wampler
explained in detail what this is
so i think i can be quick here
it's a very beautiful idea
so
you have you have to choose a start
system you choose your favorite system
consisting of the g and with the zero
zeta so it's an element of the solution
variety it should have nice condition of
course
and then what you do
somebody gives you the input f
and then you connect f and g by a smooth
curve for simplicity let's assume it's
just a straight line segment this the
simplest one can think of so i connect
those by this
line segment
and uh
right and then i let's assume that this
line along this line segment here
i denote these by the these polynomials
by q index t let's assume that none of
this q t has a multiple zero
then i can continue the zero zeta
from g to f so under this assumption
is none of the q t has a multiple zero
there exists a unique lifting
of this map t go to goes to q t to a
solution path
in the solution variety
okay so this is this is actually a
well-known topological argument
okay
so
maybe i can make a drawing here that i
can reuse later on
do you think i can remove the pizza
information
if you take notes
of the important things
so what i have here so
zero
so so my my polynomial system g is a
vector in hd so this
this board is h sub d
and uh
okay
here i have f
okay and then what did what did i say i
connect those by a straight line segment
and then i just go from here to here
with constant speeds let's say here this
is q sub d
this is one minus t
g plus t f
okay now somehow with this picture i do
emphasize the euclidean nature of this
picture but on the other hand i said
everything happens in projective space
projective space is hard to draw so i
draw a
sphere or if you want this is a
circle
so actually i can project everything
here on the sphere
so
the length of the vectors actually
don't matter the only thing that matters
is where you are on the sphere so it's a
thing about angles angles i go from here
to here okay but
i will explain later why this is
important
okay
okay so then the question is what is the
step size i mean if you go from here to
here i mean you will subdivide you okay
you will have steps of different sizes
uh
okay and then one can figure out
the following algorithm you have a step
size here
assume you are at qr you want to go to
qi plus one and here what what do i
suggest the step size should be
proportional to one over the square of
the condition number at the
approximation you are currently it's a
suggestion yeah
and i can do it this way
okay but just
just keep in mind that this distance
here this is an angular distance okay
this is a this defines an algorithm okay
so i i'm okay i'm okay i'm a bit dizzy
so this was launch i had too much launch
so i if i am
okay i have this approximation
okay
and what do i do
i replace q i by q i plus one
okay i
move on a little bit
and
what is the idea um
the idea is i should
okay
i want to have that c i is an
approximate zero to q i in this
strict sense that i define before in the
in the sense of the gamma theorem
now what i do is
if i go from q i to q i plus one i want
to make sure that c i is still an
approximate zero to q i plus one
so i know that and i want when i make
want to make this formula i need to keep
track of what happens with the condition
if i go from here to here so but this
can be settled by some leap sheets
property
okay so i
if i figure out if i do it this way then
what i do
in order to get the zi plus one
i apply one newton iteration here
but with regard to the qi plus one
okay this
is what i wrote here
so this is the
definition of this adaptive linear
homotopy adaptive linear property alh
okay so this is the algorithm if you
want you can implement it
and the it's the question is oh my time
is running the question is uh what is
the complexity what is the complexity of
this procedure
okay let's denote it this way k like
complexity
uh depends on this triple so g zeta is
the input pair f is now is the starting
system f is the input pair this is the
number of
newton continuation steps okay
okay then
basically there was an analysis of this
procedure it
implicitly was already in the bezu
series but mike schub wrote an important
paper bizu6
where he essentially proved this
he bounded the number of steps of this
homotopic method by this integral it's
the integral of the squared condition
number
along the curve
in hd so along in this situation it
would be
along this line segment but it's a very
general result so it's a curve integral
so if you want to understand the
complexity we have to deal with this
integral
okay
so uh
okay what are the several issues okay
and it's a long story and it's hard to
explain
let me tell you in an hour so
uh
gamma is the
okay it's the continuation so
this is the solution path but thanks
it's the solution path
solution path
oh there's an is an error it's an error
should be sorry it should be qt dot i'm
sorry thank you
this is an error okay
okay
how to choose this looks uh
no
everything is defined except for the
question how to choose the start system
and actually this is the most difficult
problem
locker proof uh that almost all
elements in the solution variety of are
good in the sense that the
condition is bounded by a polynomial in
n
but we don't know how to efficiently
construct such a star system it's this
problem that we have encountered here
during this problem it's the problem to
find hay in haystack so
take any one at random it will be good
nobody knows how to construct it
so
okay but what do we do if we have this
hey in haystack situation we try
randomization
okay so uh
okay so let me
what does randomization mean so what we
could do
we could say okay let's choose
g
uniformly at random
where well
i said that the the norm of g doesn't
play any rule so let's for instance
choose g in the sphere belonging to hd
uniformly at random alternatively we may
say okay
let's think of gaussian distribution
let's choose g
according to the standard gaussian
distribution so
using this
density okay
so if we if we have a g that is chosen
this way and we normalize it what we get
is of course we get the uniform
distribution on the sphere
okay it has no implication
on this algorithm okay
so uh right
so let me define a distribution of a
solution variety
okay in two steps just it's a mind it's
a thought experiment it's not something
that you actually do
first
you choose your g here from the standard
gaussian distribution
and then almost surely it will have bizu
number many zeros you choose one of them
uniformly at random
okay this way you get a pair g cetera
and i call it the standard distribution
okay of course you can't do this
efficiently this way because
i mean we are talking about efficiently
solving systems of polar equations but
you can turn it around this was a very
nice observation by carlos beltran with
miguel pardo
and they realized one can officially
sample in the solution variety by kind
of turning this around
okay and if we have this
um then
okay we we find this using randomization
and use this pair then as to start the
homotopy
to homotopy so we get the
las vegas algorithm lv
so on input f we draw the start system
at random
and then we run the adaptive linear
homotopy
this is an algorithm a randomized
algorithm
randall what's yes meaning of this
choose
your hand in zeros uh i mean it's uh
what is for you
okay
this is a way of defining a probability
i say choose but in print i define a
probability distribution
okay
i mean if i have chosen g standard
gaussian then i know almost surely i
have pizzuna person number many zeros
they exist then pick one of them at the
random uniform you had random i think of
it
this defines a probability distribution
i don't actually do it just to define it
okay okay
good so
i have a i have an algorithm
uh uses randomization
now okay it's a bit tricky
so uh because it uses randomization i
i want to talk about expected running
time so what i have here i have this
function k f g zeta and i take the
expectation over g and theta
then what i get is a function which only
depends on f k f is the complexity of
the input f
so this
and then
again what the peltrano pardo proved
um
okay let's now take let's take the
average of kf over all f
so this is another okay
this is maybe very confusing like the g
zeta is like random coins something like
it helps you in the algorithm and this
is uh taking an average over the input
space
okay they proved this beautiful result
that the expectation of kf is bounded by
this very small quantity capital d i
probably forgot what is capital d it's
the maximum of the
degree of the di i haven't i think i
forgot to write it i'm sorry
no no you have to distinguish
this d which is the maximum on this
calligraphic d which is the bezel number
it's not the same okay so so this is a
small d
it's just okay
if quadratics quadratic sim is just two
to the three half
times
number of coefficients times number of
variables so it's a very small bound
it's very polynomial
much much less
much much less that's the amazing thing
that's very amazing i guess that's
because you're just finding one you
think it's because you're
of course if you want to find all that
but if you try to to find just one zero
using revenue basis
you know
okay that's why we use numerix
that's right that's right and
okay okay okay
now what is this boost exactly at least
i wanted to state the theorem correctly
so again
back to the smooth analysis at the
beginning of my talk i just had this
drawing but now it's more formal
so what do i do
i fix an f bar in ht and i have a
positive number sigma which is like the
standard deviation
then i look at the isotropic gaussian
on the input space hd with mean f bar
and variance sigma square it's yeah and
the density is this this
expression just defines it
and then we have this
you know this is the usual notation for
denoting this
okay and then we have there is a
technical issue
don't okay don't worry
for uh okay for the purpose of the
analysis we do truncate this gaussian
so uh
okay what do we do
okay so this this
the expectation of the norm of f is
roughly square root of two n so believe
me it's uh so we truncate there
so i mean actually what you
yeah
i don't want to write a density but you
can also truncate that 10 times this it
doesn't really matter so we won't be we
don't want to have this
distribution to have a tail so we just
cut it off but but because it goes down
exponentially it doesn't make a big
difference but it simplifies the
analysis so we truncate it but that's a
technical issue so i denote this by this
index t here
and then this is the result with felipe
the smooth analysis of these las vegas
algorithms is this
so you see
you take now we take the local average
here
over the function kf
you can take the supremum over all f bar
so actually i have to put this condition
here that the norm of f bar is one other
otherwise this is not a good model here
so
otherwise i should scale the variance
with sigma that's uh
you the supremum over this local
expectation is bounded by this you see
it's like in the beltramp
d to the three half capital n small n
divided by sigma
is it sigma square
sigma
sigma okay
so
so that's uh
okay i think
so i think now you see
okay you can think of yourself what the
beginning of this is i mean it's it's i
think it's a much better result than
just having average you take any system
you perturb it a little bit
then you run the algorithm then you
solve something of course you don't
solve your original system you solve a
third system but you find a solution
very quickly
yes sure so i guess it is isotropic
gaussian that means you are perturbating
in every direction right right right uh
but you know
for depending on your fixed part your
direction closeness to the discriminant
variety could change
one direction could be worse than the
other one is there a way to perturb this
a little bit and make it non-isotropic
depending on your
fifth point
yeah it has to do i mean this question
is related to the following question
when you
i mean
you want to do the homotopy and when you
do the homotopic you want to avoid the
discriminant variety so i mean you you
cannot come if you can come up with all
kinds of clever ways of avoiding
the discriminant variety but i don't see
a simple way that i could
analyze
you can come up with all kinds of ideas
but i think if you want to do an
analysis like we did you have to come up
with something very clean otherwise it's
impossible to analyze i'm just trying to
yeah of course yeah yeah but you're
right you're right so some steps are
more dangerous and some directions are
more dangerous than others
okay
okay and then let's go quickly so what
did we do this near solution to summary
10 17's problem i think somehow this is
probably the
cleanest result that we had but the as a
byproduct of that smooth analysis
was that we could find this
deterministic algorithm for small 17's
problem
and what did we do
okay
so uh
well
what do we choose as a start system yeah
we just choose this system this is the
system here
where the roots are these tuples of
roots of unity and it was also in the
talk by charles one but it seems that
people have used that a long time we
just used that
and that the problem with this system is
that the condition is uh quite big
it's uh something like n to the d t is
the maximum degree you see if d is 2
it's okay
but if the degree is big this is not a
nice start system it has a large
complexity
so that's
okay
so what we did
okay we said the following uh let's
assume the maximal degree is less than n
then we run our adaptive linear homotopy
and if the d is greater than n so what
we do or we switch
the world and we do symbolic methods
essentially so yes we use methods from
computer algebra
so there was a an analysis
by jim rennicker which was
well
used it was numerical not just symbolic
you can just use that
this takes roughly capital d to the n
steps
and if you do the you know if you do
your numerics then you see that
okay
you get this bound here so
i can be more precise for instance if
the maximum degree is less than or equal
to n to the one minus epsilon for some
fixed epsilon
then this end to the d
the entity is the bad thing here because
that's the bound for the of the
condition of the initial system this end
to the d
is polynomial bounded in capital n this
is just some
you know dealing with the numbers
and similarly if the maximal degree is
greater than n to the one plus epsilon
you can bound now not n to the d but d
to the n
it as a polynomial capital a so this
doesn't have a deep meaning it's just
how it is
okay
the back case this is the if capital d
equals n
okay then we just get this
so somehow this is not the right
algorithm you see the this homotopic is
nice if the degrees are small but if
they are bigger
one should have something else so i feel
it's not the final answer
but it works
one can prove the theorem
okay so how is my time 15 minutes
on the proof okay i still have
decide what to explain
okay what is the proof
okay i want to show you
let's go back
okay i want to
show you actually how this works
but
okay for to keep it simple let's assume
we are in the average situation so
actually i show you how one can prove
the beltram pardo result
this one
will be the idea of cautions
okay
so uh
so there is a
main auxiliary result
and it's the following
okay
so we we have some q in h sub t
and it has a almost surely it will have
bizoo number many zeros
for each zero zeta we have this pair q
zeta and it has a condition
okay
and then i take i have the vector of all
these conditions and i think you have
two norm
so this is i take i have here the sum of
the squares of these conditions divide
by the visual number take the square
root this i call the mean square
condition number
okay the mean square condition number
the main auxiliary result is like the
machine in all these things in these
proofs is the following result
so what do we have here
the square of the mean square condition
number divided by this
the square norm this quantity
we analyze we do a smooth analysis of
this quantity here you see we have a
local expectation over q with any q bar
sigma square supremum overall q bar
of norm 1 we bound this
by a constant time
n times n over sigma square
okay so this is the
now i have okay i have
only 50 minutes left so i wanted to show
you
two things i wanted to show you
how to
come up with the average analysis
using this main auxiliary result it was
one thing and the other thing i wanted
to give you an idea
how to prove this
so
probably i'll just show you the second
thing and i leave out the first i cannot
probably you're all tired like me but
let's make it short i tell you some of
the ideas what is behind this okay
the disadvantage is that you won't see
why it is so nice to use gaussians
but
okay
now can we switch off this middle thing
not too right on the wall
so it's it's about the proof of this
main auxiliary result yeah
so let's recall
the solution variety so it's this
incidence variety consisting of these
pairs q zeta
okay q is in my space h sub t
okay
now iffy right
okay for the
for the purpose of the talk actually
doesn't matter at all
this is the solution variety
actually what you take here the sphere
but
it doesn't really matter
so
the idea is somehow to reduce to the
case which is linear so there is a
special case
there's a special case where all the
degrees
are linear
all these degrees
are one
okay that's the case we want to solve a
system of linear equations that we
believe we all understand
so in what is in this special situation
what do we have an input consists of n
linear forms
okay a linear form is a row of a matrix
okay so the i can encode it
as an n by n plus one matrix
i know that you are all tired i can see
that
okay let the calligraphic m
is my abbreviation of the space of n
times m plus on matrices
now the solution right in this special
case consists of the pairs m zeta
okay in calligraphic m times c
okay times
p n such that m theta equals zero
okay
good
and now
i look at the following map as frank
notice that both
these are these are vector bundles okay
these are both vector bundles and now i
write a bundle map
from v to w
then i denote
psi do i do
okay i map q zeta
to m zeta
you see the base point is the same so
it's a map of vector bundles
okay and now let me define this m
probably you have forgotten but
this is this quantity that that arises
then when i define the condition number
the important thing is this
i take
q okay think of this q
what is q
q
is q1
up to cqn
and i can think of it as a polynomial
map from cn plus one to cn
okay so i can take the derivative i can
take the derivative of this thing at
zeta
and this is a matrix
in the space calligraphic m and then i
decorate it i have to
post multiplied with this diagonal
matrix which is
not so important for us at the moment
for the proof very important but for the
global
rough understanding that's important
right and then
by definition by definition
i know this condition of the pair q zeta
divided by the norm of q is exactly
the operator norm of this pseudo inverse
of
m so that was my definition of the
condition
okay if you remember in the slide it was
f instead of q but it's the same the
condition of q zeta is the norm of q
times this norm of this matrix
okay
so
now
okay so
so what do we want to unders
so in order to prove this main technical
result
so we what do we have we have this
squared means this
square of the mean square condition
divided by the square norm
and we need to bound the expectation of
this over this
non-standard gaussian
now
maybe
erase
and erase this i think
i won't use it
let me put the diagram here
okay
uh so
if you recall
i defined a distribution on the solution
variety i said
choose g uniform g was gaussian and then
one of the root uniformia drama now
replace this
okay
i can do the same here if i choose q
now it's not a standard gaussian it's
just this non-centered gaussian
and after choosing it i choose one of
the zeros uniformly at random i can do
the same
and
this way i define some probability
distribution on this
solution variety
okay it can be quite complicated because
it comes from something non-centered
okay
so then i have this bundle map
psi
goes from v to w
okay now this probability distribution
defines a push forward distribution here
so i get here some probability
distribution
just push forward
okay
okay now
the first observation is that this
this expectation
i want to estimate is the same
as the expectation of
mu
zeta squared divided by norm of q
squared
with respect to distribution
on v that i defined before
so this because big what is this
what is this mu 2 squared it's just the
average over all the cont of all the
squares of the conditions so if you
think about it for a moment if you're
not too tired not too tired then you
realize it's exactly this
okay
so i have this expectation on v now but
you see this is
the square of the operator norm of the
pseudo inverse
this
only depends okay on the element here
okay only on this guy
so
this is the same
i'll just write here
this expression
alright so i have to what i have to
analyze is the x as the expectation of
this squares operator loan with respect
on the to the push forward distribution
on w i just write w but i mean the p
forward distribution okay
good uh
right and so
next
now the elements of w have two
components m and c so i think it's
important here to think
probabilistically then after that one
has to write down all the formulas but
what i can do is i can
okay i can choose okay right if i
i have this map here
goes here
so this distribution of w defines here
another distribution
okay if i would
start here with the gaussian
the standard gaussian then i would get
get here the uniform distribution but in
this situation is something more
complicated it probably concentrates
somewhere some distribution okay so what
i can say is uh just again as a mind
experiment i choose zeta according to
distribution
and then i choose m in the fiber of this
map so this map has a fiber
jekyll w zita
the fiber
is a vector space consisting of all
those matrices m such that m z equals
zero
so what i want to do
i want to write this as a iterated
expectation expectation x of expectation
so here the expectation is over zeta in
pn
and then the expectation is over m in
the fiber
of this thing
okay there are some technicalities that
one has to
okay
if you want to jump justify this prob
you have i'm sure you have seen this
usually when you apply this then you are
in in the situation of a product of two
spaces and then if you want to justify
this theoretically useful beanie
the problem is here that you don't have
a product but it's about it you have
this this bundle
so then in this
so
there are some
deformations taking place here that you
can take into account by using the co
area formal so the co area formula is
one of the
main tools this is like
it's like the transformation formula
of calculus where you don't have
isomorphisms but things that have
kernels
so
it's also generalizes to beanies so this
this you need if you want to make this
formal but this the idea is just this
okay
and then uh right we have to
okay then one have to has to prove some
lemma
because
what i want to do now i want to bound
this guy so i fix the zeta and i want to
bound this
okay and the goal is i want to bound it
i want to bound this expectation by some
constant this constant does not depend
on zeta
times n over sigma squared
if i can do that okay
then
it doesn't matter that i don't
understand too well what kind this
distribution of pn i can just bound this
by the same constant
times n sigma squared
okay that's the idea
so on the in order to prove i mean
this red thing here
so
if i want to prove that i need to
understand what is the distribution on
this fiber
maybe
let me write this and then i stop
induced distribution
on the fiber
has the density
okay so
i didn't explain it
like that
as a density of this form
and this row here
this is a
non-centered
dausion
on
w zeta w z is a vector space so this
gaussian is somehow induced
from from this q bar here i started with
a nonsensical gaussian which has a
center q bar and this somehow defines
this but i don't have time to explain it
but it's a gaussian it's a friendly
distribution
okay something we like
and then
it turns out that it gets multiplied
with the squared determinant of this
oh
i shouldn't have written m probably i
should write m sorry
i should write m m
i should write it this way i think
because it's not a square matrix
i should write it this way and this
comes from the disco area formal some
normal jacobian thing
so okay so this is one has to prove and
then once you are here then if you look
at this then proving this inequality
which i have in this red circle
boils down to some smooth analysis of a
matrix condition number if you want so
we are in a situation where we just have
matrices
and
okay so that's uh
this of course one has to prove as well
and this is the idea
of proving this main technical lemma on
time over time and thank you for your
attention